[Music]
medicine
is miraculous we have developed drugs
that can go into individual cells change
the dna
and cure genetic diseases
we have developed robots that can do
surgery
through an incision no bigger than a
coin
we were even able to make a vaccine
against covid19
in under 12 months
but let me tell you how these miracles
play out
on the ground chris was a 63 year old
man
he grew up in a family of five and he
took his first job
selling carpets door to door eventually
he worked his way up and opened a carpet
store
in the evenings he enjoyed a glass of
wine with dinner
he'd smoked since he was a teenager and
he had high blood pressure
chris hated going to see the doctor
he could never get through on the phone
he could never find a parking space
and he never saw the same doctor twice
but one year after getting back from
holiday
he had some stomach pain that just
wasn't going away
so he decided to make an appointment
when he walked into the doctor's office
that friday morning
he was greeted with a familiar sight and
sounds of a full waiting room
and you can see why the doctor only had
15 minutes to see each patient
and in that time she had to go over
their previous records
find them from the waiting room talk to
them perform an examination form a
diagnosis
prescribe treatments make any referrals
explain it to the patient
and finally write everything down
but chris's case was routine
he just got back from holiday and
stomach pain is really common
so the doctor just said take these
medicines and come back in a few weeks
if it's no better
but a few weeks passed and the pain
hadn't gone away
so chris made another appointment indeed
this time
he saw a different doctor and they came
to the same conclusion
saying it's probably the same thing
take the medicine for a bit longer we'll
send some blood tests just to be sure
and we'll get in touch if anything's
wrong
but a few weeks passed and chris was
feeling
just awful so he went back
for a third time taking yet another day
off work
and when he got there it was clear that
something was very wrong
he'd developed a life-threatening
infection
and required urgent admission to
hospital when he got to the hospital
it turned out the infection was being
caused by a cancer
they managed to clear the infection but
the cancer was inoperable
and six months later chris passed away
what is so extraordinary
about his story is just how ordinary it
is
we have all of these amazing
technologies
but we can't get the basics right in
reality
i saw hundreds of patients like chris
whilst working as a doctor
he'd actually had scans at another
hospital the year before
but they weren't available to the doctor
when she was making diagnosis
he had blood tests sent but they weren't
checked and followed up in a timely
manner
because the doctor had no time allocated
to do so and no software or technology
to help her flag abnormal results
and finally guidelines suggest that
patients like chris
should be referred for immediate
investigations after their first visit
but with the amount and volume of
information that's being published
every day there's no chance any human
could possibly stay on top of it
without the help of technology
i tell you chris's story
not because he was one of my patients
but because he was my father
and it was going on his patient journey
with him that made me realize just how
big the gulf is
between what is possible and that
which everyday people actually receive
in healthcare
inefficiencies error and waste in
healthcare
cost one trillion dollars
every year and they leave the
preventable death
of 250 000 americans to put that in
context
that is the same amount of money as the
entire economy of mexico
healthcare is broken but i believe
that with three principles we can fix it
design for patients equip clinicians for
success
and align industry incentives
design for patients when it comes to
healthcare
patients are forced to navigate an
impossibly complex and opaque
landscape of insurers payers
providers and when they do receive care
it's in a way that is most convenient
for the clinician
not the patient
this wouldn't happen in any other
industry
you can order take away a taxi
or even access heavily regulated
industries like banking from tap
the phone why should healthcare be any
different
patients deserve better
you should demand healthcare that is
high quality
easy to navigate and delivered in a way
that is convenient to you
and you can vote with your feet get
health insurance policies that support
providers that are delivering just this
sort of service
equip clinicians for success
when you think of the cutting edge of
industry what do you think of
perhaps companies that use ai machine
learning
share information using platforms like
slack
or at the very least maybe they use a
computer rather than paper
how would they do without any of these
when i worked for the uk's national
health service i worked
a stone's throw away from the uk's
epicenter for digital health
affectionately known as silicon
roundabout
yet i sent referrals by fax
contacted colleagues by pager and wrote
prescriptions
on paper and this is the case all over
the world
it takes on average 17 years for
innovations to move from concept
to clinic when it comes to clinicians
being able to deliver excellent care we
cannot change the human condition
but we can change the conditions in
which humans work
patients deserve better providers need
to equip doctors with the tools to
deliver care
in an efficient and convenient manner
they need to celebrate the operational
the mundane the bread and butter not
just the headline making discoveries
it is much better to have a simple
machine that functions well
than a complex machine that barely
functions at all
align industry incentives
the author of the armchair economist
stephen linzberg
described all of economics in four words
people respond to incentives
and healthcare is constructed in a way
the volume
not outcomes are incentivized fix as
many hips as possible perform as many
scans as possible
prescribe as many drugs as possible
and these incentives are key drivers of
provider behavior
but not all action is good unnecessary
surgery can lead to debilitating side
effects
unnecessary scans expose patients to
radiation
that increases the risk of cancer and
the overuse of prescription medications
can lead to dependency and addiction
patients deserve better
policymakers need to construct
incentives that reward
health not wealth
and as consumers of healthcare you need
to ask is this treatment in my best
interest
i believe that it is in the operational
but overlooked
that there is the biggest opportunity to
improve healthcare
i believe that working together we can
create a healthcare system
with people like my father in mind one
that puts patients first
equips clinicians for success and
incentivizes health
not wealth so i invite you to join me
and help put the miracle back in
medicine
thank you